hey welcome back so today we're working
on a 2022 or late 2022 early 23 Toyota
Camry it's going to be using this Flip
Key a lot of people have trouble with
this and I'm going to show you how to do
this in pretty quick easy and I will
have uh links down below for the other
video on how to work on this key we're
going to be using the altel 508 uh let's
go ahead and get started let's do manual
selection we want to program the remote
first we have the new key as well so we
have North
America oh I clicked on the wrong
thing so it's Toyota my
bad manual
selection
USA
caming and we have this year range it's
a blade key
and let's do control unit so you want to
do the remote
first so let's do remote learning we're
going to want to put the key in the
ignition turn to the on
mode now it's turned on it's able to
think driver doors open
[Music]
great and interesting thing I noticed
with the all tail it's going to going to
be 1 second hold while smart Pro 4
second hold don't know why but it's just
interesting how different programmers do
different things to get the same
results so it has to prep and get ready
I'm just going to put it on my my leg
right here so we can see and I can use
both hands
okay I'm we just going to press one and
then
press and done you hear that Toyota beep
cool okay and I'm going to take the
key
out their buttons obviously still work
[Music]
cool and then let's go ahead and see if
we go through and let's do the mobilizer
let's go through hot function and let's
do add
key so let's go ahead and see what it
says let's go ahead and put the key in
on
mode yes
okay that's the VIN
yes
yes so you're going to say oh no what
the heck happened it didn't work because
it's it's the nasta tis all that stuff
so we're going to go ahead and go back
and we're going to go ahead and get that
immobilizer done with the other tool
I'll show you
so we're just going to escape we don't
need this
anymore and let's go ahead and finish
okay so coming back what I did is I used
the xhorse and I cloned the key the chip
in here made a new chip I'm going to pop
it in here and then we will get started
and then we're going to cut the blade
after and we're all done there's going
to be links Down Below in the
description on how to do this step by
step so I open it up I'm going to take
out that chip by breaking it and and
then putting the new chip in so I took
the chip out broke it out broke out that
wall and then put some loctip Putty in
there to hold it in place so it doesn't
um bind and jam on that roller shoulder
other than that right I'm going to go
ahead and assemble cut the keyblade and
crank it in the condition and we are
good to
go okay so we cut it manually on the key
line 303 and we're good let's go ahead
and stick it in the ignition and crank
this car on okay let's go ahead and try
the new key
starts the vehicle and all good to go
this took about 10 minutes max to go
from start to finish other than that
have a great day and I will see you next
time see you bye